on this episode of Imagine a world in
this story something we've already seen
some evidence by climate change maybe
compromising or risking certain island
nations in the Pacific where they now
lose connection to their land and who
want to maintain a sense of community
but don't have a land to assign that
Community to now start seeing if they
can yeah use the digital Nation as a
represented and recognized member of the
global Arena
welcome to imagine a world a mini series
from the future of Life Institute
this podcast is based on a contest we
ran to gather ideas from around the
world about what a more positive future
might look like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as f-aligned or positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to imagine a world I'm your host
Guillaume reason
in this episode we'll be exploring a
world called digital Nations which was
one of the third place winners of fli's
World building contest
as the name suggests this world has a
deep dive into virtual communities
it explores how people might find
belonging and representation on the
global stage through digital Nations
that aren't tied to any physical
location
this world also features a fascinating
and imaginative kind of artificial
intelligence that they call digital
persons
these are inspired by biological brains
and have a rich internal psychology
rather than being trained on data
they're considered to be raised in
digital nurseries
they have a nuanced but mostly loving
relationship with Humanity but some even
going on to found their own digital
Nations for us to join
the promise of this world to me is that
new technologies might provide new
opportunities to bring people together
the challenges of safely navigating new
kinds of intelligence may offer a chance
to know ourselves and each other more
deeply leading to wiser and gentler
societies
this world was created by a team of
three from Nairobi Kenya our guests
today are Tracy shundu and Conrad
Whitaker Tracy is a science educator
with a background in chemistry she's the
co-founder and CEO of funky science
which creates affordable at-home science
kits for kids
Conrad is a startup advisor and
entrepreneur who works with startups in
the clean tech talent management and
fintech sectors their third teammate
Dexter Findley is an author filmmaker
and photographer who works in the
humanitarian sector
well hey Conrad and Tracy thanks so much
for joining us
it's great to be here Hi how are you
quite well thanks
um how did the three of you come to work
together on this there's U2 and Dexter
Findlay is your third teammate who's not
here with us today yeah that's right I
don't know how it really started but I
uh had prior previously read some of
Mac's techmark's books who had fli and
then through that found out about this
competition
um and so then I reached out to a
comrade in arms Dexter who's been a good
friend of mine since the first day I
arrived in Kenya back in 2014.
um and you know we have a lot of shared
interests
and so we very much vibed on this
um on this topic we spent a lot of time
building this world but we thought
something was clearly missing uh so we
went out to to Tracy here to join us to
provide some extra perspective and some
of our acting skills maybe I'll let
Tracy introduce herself uh so when
Conrad first approached me to to help
them out with this project
um of course Conrad being not just
um a regular friend but a friend of the
entire family
um we he reached out and asked would you
mind doing some of these things and
helping us out and I felt it was
wonderful experience to learn something
different and something new and also to
challenge myself
yeah can you each say a little bit about
your backgrounds and kind of what
brought you to where you are today
yeah in a professional capacity I've
been in in Ken in well I guess Africa
for nine out of 10 years now
um and primarily working in the startup
ecosystem uh working uh with with young
companies and helping them scale and
I've always had this uh kind of
intellectual or curious uh attachment to
to I guess the future and and to various
philosophical topics
um and that's how I found myself in this
uh reading some of these books that that
connected to this competition
um just to introduce Dexter as well yeah
um Dexter is truly a Renaissance Man and
a very good friend but he's very
multifaceted so he's he's a Movie Maker
he's a self-published author widely read
uh an archaeologist an astronomer and I
think yeah he has very colorful
background and um he's a good friend
which both Tracy and and the family and
and me and my family
um and he's just moved back to the UK
with with his family
um leaving us us here in Kenya
um but that's that's kind of the bit of
the context
uh and for me my background is around
science so
um I love chemistry particularly so
um a lot of my work and a lot of my
learning has been industrial chemistry
environmental chemistry building around
that but
um from all that work around science I
sort of also wanted to speak to a
science Community within Kenya and
that's what prompted us now uh with my
co-founder back in University to sort of
create a system and a space where people
could speak about science but we found
out that we don't have a lot of adults
people listening to sciencey talk so we
decided you know why not go a bit low
and sort of influence younger Minds
because they haven't formed an opinion
that science is difficult and science is
hard but brings me to now a company
which we created was called uh funky
science so sort of making science fun
for children and making it more
relatable to them so that uh they don't
have the solution at times it's hard or
difficult but also manageable I'm
curious to hear some some of the things
that you both learned as part of working
on this contest and going through the
process of World building for it it's
hard and and I think the the way the the
structure was created where you have to
have a timeline
um that I think was kind of completed at
the very end literally the day before
um and and to make a world that's
consistent every year and plausible and
aspirational
um was it was was tricky and certainly
we wanted to provide the kind of outside
perspective but perhaps a bit more
non-western-centric perspective you know
part of the project was looking at
various data points
um that might not be top of mind to
other audiences and you know note those
changes so these would be the
undercurrent events that were just as
fundamental and impactful and important
but it was of course because they're
under current harder to to think about
um so really spending the time to to
force oneself to think about it was was
a bit of teeth pulling and I think that
all of us
um but I you know it's it's something
that I think we feel quite happy with
ultimately we look back on this project
with some fondness and some pleasure
some of the details we have forgotten
and so it was a pleasure kind of
rereading our world in preparation for
this podcast
and definitely for me to learning also
something new that I didn't
um no of or understand or even wants to
put the energy into understanding but
working with Conrad index that sort of
also brought to light different things
that I didn't understand it also sort of
align some of the assumptions I had you
know
um when you don't want to immerse
yourself into something new then you
just assume it is something difficult
and I do not want and think about it but
working with Conrad index I also
actually forced me to you know leave
that comfort zone of I will live with
this assumption and just move on with my
life and which is not how which is not a
very intentional way of living in which
is also how majority of people live but
sort of also force you to read more
learn more you know um question more not
just stay with whatever knowledge that
you have at the moment but also expand
and learn more about
um different concepts different ideas
and also broadened also my view on some
the subject matter that we were
discussing which was well it was heavy
but it was something new and I enjoyed
that part of learning it that's so cool
foreign
the first digital nation in this world
is Tonga a Polynesian kingdom whose
digital statehood is recognized by the
UN after the majority of its people are
forced to flee Rising Seas this opens
the door to other digital collectives
also seeking Global recognition the
story of Tonga turned out to be
incredibly prescient less than a year
after our winners were announced the
nearby island nation of tuvalu revealed
plans to become the world's first
digital Nation the first part of its
land that will be lost to Rising Seas
has already been digitally preserved
Bittersweet validation for the world
that Tracy Conrad and Dexter have
imagined I wanted to hear more about how
the digital Nations they conceived of
impacted the lives of the people in
their world
so I'd like to spend a little while
talking about what this world that
you've imagined looks like in the future
what is it like to live in your world
like how do people find fulfillment
around 2045 or so
in some ways The Human Condition is
probably no different in 2045 as it is
today
um you know there's still these ego
problems that we might face that people
still have problems this isn't a Utopia
I think that's something that would
never really happen uh and so I think uh
I think there's some problems we we
can't really predict that people in this
world are engaging with but in part
through the effects of technology and
and those types of Innovations
um the ability to find and maintain
relationships continues to improve and I
think this is just something that might
not be too surprising or or too out of
the box we already have begun bridging
people's communication channels uh right
now you're you're in California we're in
Kenya I don't think we'll ever replace
that fully in a metaverse
um complete artificial reality type way
with avatars there's always going to be
an umbrella over a physical reality and
we still need that that physicality uh
but but in terms of connecting with
people and overcoming those barriers
lubricating that through technology I
think um allows us to maintain various
Community communities more easily than
we might today
um when the pandemic hit uh I was in my
apartment for for many days for many
months and I felt like I could be
like someone Buenos Aires I could be
like someone you know in Ontario um the
apartment itself is pretty standard and
yet in 2045 I'd hope and expect that we
can Bridge some of those caps to those
people more directly than we did and um
and from my understanding technology
sort of makes the world Limitless
so uh you can sort of have more I'd say
interactions but more knowledge and
understanding from one point to another
if if I was to allude Conrad's point of
Corona and how during the lockdown there
was a lot of limited you know movement
and limited Association but you know
sort of using technology to bridge that
Gap uh sort of brings a sort of
I'd call it community in quotes but
still removes the whole aspect of I
guess a bit of loneliness from
everything I think it's nice to imagine
like technology bringing us all together
and providing this new scaffolding for
social interactions and that's kind of
one Central thing in your world is these
digital Nations so I'm curious to hear a
little more about how you imagined that
working like how many digital nations
are there and how many would the average
person be a member of
in terms of a digital Nation right now
what do we have what 193 you know
Nations you know give or take those
secessionist movements we might not want
to count or not
um uh globally today
um I'm not sure there's going to be as
defined number in 2045 uh perhaps we
could say this about the same number of
digital Nations I think the reason is is
that it's it's a bit more of a spectrum
so uh right now you might have Facebook
Community groups or you know some other
types of collectives today you might be
in clubs and they have their website you
might be part of the Rotary Club and
what happens is just like how companies
let's say you know Facebook or Google
would have extreme amounts of power
um where their causal power among their
societies might be more than the local
Municipal governments in a similar way
some of these clubs that are now being
more and more organized by uh enabled by
by technology
um start to attain more power uh causal
power of organization
um and so forth and then what happens is
in this story something we've already
seen some evidence by
um climate change maybe compromising or
risking certain island nations in the
Pacific where they now lose connection
to their land and who want to maintain a
sense of community but don't have a land
to assign that Community to now start
um seeing if they can yeah use the the
digital Nation as a as a as a
represented and recognized member of of
the global Arena
um and so I think that that doesn't seem
too far-fetched
um so you get like an old traditional
way of seeing a community and because of
a loss of land uh the international
Arena says you know what we have to do
right by this and so let's recognize
let's say we had put Tonga but it might
be tuvalu it seems
um to recognize
um and these ones this community will
have the power of issuing passports
having their own currency but will not
necessarily be constrained by land and
and in that way we feel more and more
that we see potentially that more and
more communities will want that same
kind of Freedom that kind of
independence from the land
to which they were born and and be able
to yeah to move between citizenships and
have different types of sovereignties so
at that point in 2045 I think 200 might
be too many uh digital Nations that are
kind of causally powerful
um I think instead of seeing it as an
either or they're more just various
types of clubs that have power where
people come either registered they apply
to they get there and then they can
leave because they're not constrained so
much by the the resources that say a
given nation state today has so it's
easier to come and go and to share in
more of them so you can be kind of a a
citizen of more than one digital Nation
one thing I don't want to let slide
without commenting on is tuvalu and how
I think this is after your submission
right they they have become the world's
first digital Nation or are aiming to
they're they're scanning all of their
land and getting a digital
representation of it and ensuring that
all the people who live there have a
connection to that land before it's
threatened by climate change had you had
you heard of that in in the works before
you submitted your world we had not
actually we learned about this from you
uh
and and and I thought that was pretty
neat I think need is an understatement I
mean yeah I was watching this video they
have a website tuvalu.tv and you can see
that you know there's like this this man
giving an address at a Podium and it
slowly zooms out and you realize it's on
a beach and then there's these little
subtle graphical artifacts it's really
well done and you start to realize the
whole thing is a digital representation
of the landscape you know and he's like
there's water Rising around him it's
very dramatic but it's yeah it's it's
really strikingly on point given what
you imagined and it's also unfortunately
pretty heartbreaking but yeah because we
don't want that to happen right we want
to do an origin story for for digital
Nations but I guess um if I'm thinking
about it it's it's it it was not what
the the vision at the time but it's it's
sad that it's happened quite fast but
also slowly becoming a reality that we
should also start looking into that it's
also happening that fast so yeah it's a
two-sided sort of scenario and well it's
it's also sad losing your land something
that you've been used to that you're
familiar with and then now the other
side is also now adopting something new
[Music]
thank you
this world takes major challenges like
climate change and inequality very
seriously while great progress is
eventually made in addressing them that
progress is initially slow and uneven
the world's timeline is of course
constrained to end in 2045 but it's
clear that this team doesn't believe in
quick fixes inequality in particular
doesn't really see much improvement
until digital persons begin to suggest
new approaches to solving it
I was curious to explore Tracy and
Conrad's perspectives on dealing with
climate change and on the roles of
digital persons and shaping their world
foreign
to talk about some of the challenges
that your world faced along the way to
its end point
so one massive feature obviously is
climate change as that's kind of why you
have these digital Nations start to
emerge you have Tonga being threatened
by sea level rise suddenly the majority
of Tongans find themselves living
outside of the country and so they have
to make this move to become a digital
nation that the UN recognizes your world
fights back pretty hard against climate
change you have a lot of alternative
fuel sources you cut down at factory
farms I think you even have like
reflective materials you inject into
clouds to try to you know amp up the
greenhouse gas reflection kind of stuff
a lot of these Solutions can really only
be put into place immediately by highly
resourced countries so one thing I'm
curious about is whether your
perspective being from within Africa
affects the way you think about climate
change and how to address it I mean I
think there's there's more and more kind
of awareness of this Niche to plan for
adaptation in Africa
um I think I live in the best city in
the world at Nairobi
um and and that's partly because of its
wonderful climate it's very temperate it
never gets above 85 really maybe 90
occasionally and then never below 60
then it's winter quote unquote and so
it's a bit kind of easy to ignore
unfortunately
um the effects of climate change we do
have some less predictability when it
comes to rain but just you drive eight
hours North we have had what four or
five years of extreme drought and and so
I think I think there is already some
kind of humanitarian reactions and and
and quote unquote demand to to address
these problems
um
certainly won't be enough it's certainly
a problem but I think I just have to say
that uh I the theme that I want to
continually come back to is that
problems are solvable and you know
there's a
it's a real problem it's not something
to to put away and ignore
um but because it's solvable it's
something to address and and take
seriously and then and then but still be
hopeful that that we can adapt
um
um because just to add in I feel policy
wise
um some of the things were very slow in
terms of implementing anything around uh
climate change I think I think when the
notion was very relaxed like um some of
these effects we don't see them we don't
feel them so why should we try and
change anything but as as Conor has
mentioned for the past four years I'd
see even areas around the central
Highlands of Kenya have been quite dry
um and then you'll find certain areas
where these
um changes in even uh quantities of
water in the lake and and rainfall and
leaks emerging so I think there's a
scenario where two lakes in the Great
River are sort of merging uh that's Lake
baringo and lake bocoria and that would
actually have effects on the ecosystem
and you know a lot of people are now
speaking about some of these changes
that are happening and we have lots of
now especially speaking about a
geologists environmental scientists
actually uh trying to highlight some of
these changes is within the country so
that also people are aware so that it
doesn't seem like oh it's extreme
temperatures in ABC sort of country in
the north and it's not happening here
but
um there are actually certain changes
that have been happening so even the
discussion around the lakes on the great
shift I tell you that some that's that's
a conversation that happened maybe about
four years ago and now it's coming to
the Forefront and people are now
speaking about it uh speaking about the
changes in also of course rainfall
because even
um for many African countries and Kenya
not being left out we rely a lot on
rainfall for our agriculture so that
means now we can provide food to feed
our populations because of those changes
in the weather patterns and temperature
even Seasons I think part of a travesty
here also is that the vast majority of
the power generated in Kenya is from
renewable sources hydro and and
geothermal being you know we have the
Great Rift Valley so we have plenty of
source here so we're really not the
contributors to this problem here yeah
and it's it's kind of a yeah a sad note
there yeah that is interesting
well your your world has different
methods of trying to deal with these
changes that do impact you know the
ability to farm and things like that you
have advanced agriculture that develops
and decentralized Manufacturing free
trade and open borders through some
parts of Africa and you know you portray
this Building Wealth in a lot of African
countries but you also point out this
doesn't keep Pace with like rapid
population growth in these areas and
doesn't immediately move everyone
towards increased equality so I'm
curious if you could say a little bit
more about what life in those countries
would look like during this period of
kind of growth to meet this challenge
yeah I think there's a few points maybe
worth highlighting first off population
growth continues but I think the overall
rate by 2045 starts to slow down the
absolute value of of wealth quote
unquote goes up even if it doesn't
particularly mitigate inequality but I
do think in our story we do say that
like Congo I don't know when it's like
2038 is now declared extreme poverty
free
um and and that in part is generated by
a lot of things like liberalization of
economies of improved trade improved
governance but in terms of a lot of the
problems that we see today you know
we'll get rid of malaria by then
um and a lot of these other tropical
diseases for the for the very worst off
um that's going to happen in the next
few decades
so it's yeah it's not going to bring
things to parity
um there's still going to be uh there's
going to be an increase in in wealth but
I still think there's going to be some
distribution of that wealth in a way
that still uh helps the worst off in
society more a more equitable
distribution of the wealth to different
sort of African countries or nations I
agree with making also the trade in
Africa borderless because it's um the
reality is there are barriers left right
and center but in the creation of the
world and making it uh it was 2038 yes
and making
um the open borders because that's
that's a conversation that has been
going on severally so it's it creating
um a sort of uh idea around that
borderless travel borderless trade is is
essential also to Africa's growth
because
um with borderless travel and borderless
Street comes also exchange of ideas and
that's still so it creates an
improvement in everything that happens
in the continent
yeah and that fits in very well with
this theme of kind of weakening the
power of you know physical Nations and
the limits they have on people's
movements and behaviors
one one way that you address this
growing inequality in your world is
eventually we have these digital persons
which we'll get into exactly what those
are in a moment but basically they start
to advance our moral knowledge as well
as our other areas of knowledge like
technical scientific whatnot and they
start to encourage us to really put
effort into making the world more
Equitable I'm just curious what you
imagine it could look like to advance
moral knowledge like could you imagine
an example of how this kind of influence
from a digital person could play out I'm
definitely
um I think offending many philosophers
when I'm saying these things and this is
probably all not as legitimate as it
sounds but but I think maybe the
solution that these digital persons
bring forth are sometimes a a kind of
Third Way between a conflict when you
say which how do we address you know the
trolley problem here and and in a way
that's actually more pleasing than
either of the two existing Expeditions
um so that's kind of maybe an example of
what would be nice to see uh in terms of
moral advancement
um
yeah and I don't think we we have some
of those answers now but I think that
would be like an example of of how moral
discourse could be Advanced maybe it
could be something that the human human
could aspire to do or to be like and
probably yeah and part of it is also how
do you encourage maybe more moral
Behavior among certain types of people
um so it's not just the what is moral
but also the distribution of that idea
yeah interesting well let's get into
what these digital persons are so
talking about Advanced AI systems is
getting increasingly difficult because
they're developing so quickly and our
concepts of what they're capable of are
constantly being challenged in your
world AI systems like we know them today
like Chad GPT and Dolly turn out to be
fundamentally pretty limited so it takes
a whole different technological approach
to computation to really produce a truly
kind of intelligent system that starts
to resemble us so while systems like
Chachi BT Dali in the future whatever
comes of them might become generally
capable something we might call an AGI
which can do almost any task as well as
a human they're still not kind of truly
human-like in this deeper way and in
order to reach what you're calling
digital persons which have this kind of
vivid internal experience and human-like
nature you have to build off of what
you're calling non-vonne Neumann
architectures so can you say a little
bit about what that looks like and why
you think that could be true
yeah that's a it's a complex and
interesting question and I think like
you're saying semantics and definitions
I think probably matter to me the
difference between what we have with the
dollies and the Chachi pts today is that
yeah fundamentally they can extract the
most interesting
combinatoric you know outputs that you
have based on its training modules and
you can have these interesting new Arts
uh and pictures that are generated by
this but ultimately it's constrained so
the test I would give is like okay give
an existing AI all the knowledge we had
until 1905. we've written thing and
couldn't come up with general relativity
can it conjecture can it dream things
that hasn't been that doesn't come from
a statistical or stochastic output of
its training uh model and I don't know
what that is I don't know what the
creativity module is in humans that that
does this but the Von Neumann reference
there is something I certainly wouldn't
want to put a bet on but yeah I think we
just had to find some sort of Trope that
some sort of invention or Discovery
would come out yeah
well so speaking of these digital
persons and what their experience is
like I really enjoyed how your world
shifted language from AI training to
kind of AI upbringing and you really
leaned into these internal psychological
lives of these digital persons they need
to be kind of raised in a careful and
specific way in these digital nurseries
you say that we've tried different ways
of upbringing them and if you have a
highly controlling environment it
actually creates stunted or even kind of
suicidal digital persons I was curious
why you think that this kind of liberal
upbringing would be the most effective
for raising a digital person oh off the
bat it's just more positive but uh yes
um but uh yeah I know I think I'm afraid
of these kind of totalitarian tropes
about the future where there's a lot of
surveillance and these are the types of
of narratives that I think are ready
kind of shared and and the idea here is
that no we're just error correcting at a
higher more sophisticated level and the
best way to error correct our own
thoughts are preconceived notions is is
to have a kind of an open discourse to
be able to do that and that's how we
advance our own knowledge uh when we can
lean into our disagreements the moment
things are more suppressed the moment
things are more controlled
uh even as as us school children we then
might want to disobey we might want to
rebel and that becomes more dangerous so
the the kind of bet we take in this
world is that no you you let these
agents be themselves
um and you put them in environments that
allow them to have discourse with other
agents whether it's other digital
persons or it's humans themselves and
they'll make mistakes they'll learn from
those mistakes and because they have
this freedom to pursue to create
discover to invent new not to discover
new knowledge they they now find some
sort of contentment and can build
relationships in this kind of social
media yeah
so as you're talking about this it's
obvious that there's kind of an analogy
which makes sense since these are based
on human-like brain systems there's an
analogy between what is good for these
systems and the way that they're brought
up and what you believe is good for
human children and human people when
they're brought up it's a really
interesting angle there where like
raising these digital people could give
us a quantitative test bed to figure out
what the truly best way to raise a
human-like entity would be and I'm
curious how you could see that you know
interacting with the way that we
actually raise our human children and
specifically I'm curious of how like you
know education or the way we interact
with kids might change based on what we
learn from these digital persons
honestly it's when you cultivate a sort
of space of Freedom where it's safe for
you to express yourself to speak out
your opinions then you get a more open
sort of society where people are even
able to come up with ideas and come up
with Solutions with problems much faster
than when you create a scenario where it
is um strict closed and my way or the
highway so it sort of breeds resentment
towards uh let's say the big guy or the
boss or the one who runs the show and
sort of brings this notion that if
um if I am wrong then there's something
wrong with me but if um if I want to
express myself and want to express a
different opinion from yours it is not
that I am fighting you but it's that we
can have different opinions we can have
different thoughts and we can still
coexist yeah
I have kind of a darker Twist on that
question which is what if you imagine
that raising these digital people in a
really strict controlling kind of
oppressive environment was best for them
and they came out as more you know
effective tools or entities in the world
would that make you reconsider how we
should be you know raising our children
or running our societies as humans
well
to say that I'm open to being corrected
um kind of on principle and that if a
better explanation presents itself it
doesn't make sense for me to reject it
out of some sort of
egotistical attachment to a prior
explanation
um I think it's just hard for me to
believe that scenario uh yeah
um and and yeah so I think uh but it
would be something for me to to look
into and to try to understand where I'm
wrong uh where we're wrong and and why
that that is the case
um I think I'm fearing a little bit that
it's it's like these these fairy tales
where they say
um you know you choice is what makes you
unhappy let me just remove your choice
and so yeah
you know well you don't have to think
um now we have this Brave New World kind
of environment
um so that all problems are gone
yeah maybe they're happy in some way but
maybe not the environment or the world
that I'd like to live in and then I
would assume that if they had the full
kind of awareness that they would
probably argue or many of them not to be
in that environment either yeah I want
to go back to your video piece where
Tracy plays that digital person mama
oculi and she's kind of trying to
recruit people for her digital Nation
I'm curious why digital persons would
want people to join their Nations and
I'm also curious what you imagine they'd
be like as Leaders like would they have
any particular strengths or shortcomings
my thoughts when I was doing this was
I'm welcoming people to join my
community to join us to grow
differently to see a different
perspective of
the future to be part of a place that
has limited Limitless possibilities and
Limitless things that you could do
I think I think these uh digital persons
are nurtured by by humans and a theme
sometimes that we represent in this
story is that they're kind of our
children and so there's a bit of this
kind of upward respect to to those that
kind of birthed them for lack of a
better word and and so in part also with
their development of moral knowledge
there's this kind of desire for them to
be able to involve other moral beings
in a kind of communal way what's really
interesting in that Mama Achilles video
is that it's about persuasion it's not
about coercion it's about this is the
argument that I'm presenting I believe
with the agency that I have that this is
I think a good thing I'll let you decide
whether or not to join because you have
your own agency as well yeah I like I
like Tracy's portrayal of it as kind of
like this this passion the digital
person is kind of an ideologue that has
come to this moral View and and it just
wants to you know bring other people
along with it if they want to join
[Music]
this team's exploration of digital
Nations was very timely and not only
because of tuvalu's announcement
shortly after fly's contest ended
American investor Balaji srinivasan also
published a book called the network
state
in this book he outlines how a unified
digital Community might go about gaining
credibility as a state on the global
stage
I was curious how this team had arrived
at the concept of digital Nations right
as these conversations were beginning
I also wanted to hear how they felt
their portrayal of digital persons
related to conversations already ongoing
around the future and impact of today's
AI systems
so I'd like to take a while now to talk
about different ways that some of the
ideas in your world are currently being
thought about and portrayed in popular
media and how that compares to what
you've come up with
so the first obvious one is the concept
of a digital nation which I hadn't heard
about before reading your world you
mentioned that there has been this
portrayal of network states by Balaji
but you read that afterwards I'm curious
what was your original inspiration for
digital Nations like what went into that
concept
yeah digital Nations to us was kind of a
natural organic outcrop and ultimately
how we organize her probably you know
around the social constructs that we
accept
um if you're in a gang
um maybe that gang provides some sort of
governmental Services they have the
Monopoly on violence if you're in a more
sophisticated nation state they have
that Monopoly
um and then they provide you know the
firefighting services and so forth
um and yet you might be in that country
and you might feel limited and what we
do now with civil societies we organize
and we organize and my mother as an
example you know connected very much on
Facebook
um over the past couple of years
uh with others and I'm sure this isn't a
story that's unique to me and then you
know that she dove into politics uh from
2016 onwards
um and and and and you know that that's
provided a sense of community and so the
point for us was not to stop there what
is the next thing what are the next
instruments of power what do these
Collective groups how can they change
things causally
um and what would be the epitome of the
most powerful type of organization you
know one might say it's a company the
other might say it's a country so we
would just expect that more and more of
these digitally organized communities
start sharing their own maybe coins
digital coins that can only be used and
transacted with other members of that
Community
um you know now you get some
representation or acknowledgment from
other parties and so now you're seen as
legitimate in some way and this is how
the nation-state uh Community accepts
those from digital sorry from from
islands that are submerging in this
story
um and so yeah it was just this natural
progression that led to this idea of
digital Nations and then we didn't
continue and I think Balaji continued
yeah
I'm curious to hear from Tracy about
perceptions of Dolly and GPT I mean it
sounds like this the digital Nations
concept I mean it's kind of just
starting to become something anybody is
thinking about and so it's sort of in
its infancy and it makes sense that
people might be a little more dismissive
of its potential impact and value but
we're really starting to see this shift
where I've seen a lot more respect and
interest in in systems like Dolly and
chat gbt and I'm curious particularly
about how younger people are seeing
these systems like have you have you
heard any discussion among your students
or or kids that you are working with
um it's interesting that you'd asked
that because uh from what I've seen
maybe locally it's it's
um I would say it's younger students
talking about it it's more of uh
conversations happening around
universities
and also uh how students are interacting
with some of these tools to do
um tasks that they've been given or
assignments uh I've had this especially
around in universities a lot
um high school and maybe elementary
students so primary here I've not had
that conversation but in University it's
more of around uh now writing so what
what essays are being done using some of
these tools I'm even sort of setting an
exam and then getting the AI to Mark the
exam for you you know so you know we
sort of even tried some of these things
of asking and setting and you know
pushing the limits of how what it can
create for us I had never thought about
that angle of the Educators and the
parents using these tools themselves in
their teaching I love that flip that's
really funny I can now imagine like a
whole classroom where the students are
submitting AI written articles and the
teacher is judging them with ai
ai as a teacher imagine
yeah that's really interesting well as
someone who who spends a lot of time
thinking about how to encourage young
people to engage with science do you
have any thoughts about how we might be
able to use these systems to to help us
do that like how can we actually engage
people and the types of people who
aren't necessarily engaged with certain
topics like in stem for example using
these tools so as I mentioned the danger
of some of these tools is of course not
encouraging thinking but you could also
still use them to push different thought
processes so prompt and ask as often as
you can so it would be around creating
programs that create
um that push for creative thinking then
for working together so one thing that
we have seen with some of the things
that we do especially around a the
programs that we're creating now is also
encouraging that sort of think outside
what you're doing question everything
and don't just leave it at where it is
so
um as much as these tools give us an
easy and simpler answer question the
answer at the end of the day and make
sure make sure that is this the best
answer that I've gotten out of this or
is this the best outcome that I've
gotten out of this system
um because the fear continues being that
if we continue delegating our thinking
to
um
to some of these tools then at the end
of the day are we breeding more
so the audio cut out a little bit there
but to clarify Tracy said creating more
zombies it's it's
just
um me and my co-founder
um and we are really sort of sitting
down and thinking deeper and being a bit
more critical and a bit more doing
things with a lot more purpose and
intention so that at the end of the day
we are not just telling you okay we
created this and we can do this what do
you think but more of uh moving together
with some of our participants in our
programs so um asking questions uh to
some of the girls who do the program are
you comfortable when you do this are you
feeling out of place when you do this uh
what happens What feelings do you get
when you're doing this uh do you feel
that by using this tool your work has
been simplified you know probing further
so that we don't just leave everything
up in the air and I think
um by that I'm getting that you know
it'll also create a comfortable space
where there's more expression uh there's
more communication there's more
collaboration and we could also just
incorporate both tools so practical
learning and then just using any of
these AI tools to just help natural
education and nurture growth
yeah I also I really like that point
that you made about how it could
encourage you to continue questioning
and to check the answer that you get
more because that made me suddenly
realize I mean this is not a new problem
we've had textbooks which have just been
like really worse versions of these
tools that also have their own errors in
them you know and misrepresentations and
no one has really thought very much
about teaching students to question
textbooks but maybe they should and
maybe this will just be a forcing
mechanism that'll encourage us to really
teach these deeper knowledge findings
and learning skills that'll be necessary
to ensure the quality of the information
they're getting later in life I I agree
with you yes that's true
one other thing that I really enjoyed in
your world is this whole kind of
psychological experience of digital
persons so again these these digital
persons are like somewhat sci-fi fantasy
they're they're not necessarily just an
extension of chat GPT kind of thing
there there's some imagined future
entity that is somewhat like us but is
digital and I found exploring what that
could be like for them just really
fascinating like one thing you mentioned
is that they don't necessarily want to
upgrade themselves super quickly and
become scary you know as some people
imagine an advanced AI system might
because it can impact their sense of
self so suddenly becoming a different
computational system would be kind of a
shock to them and maybe they would be
slower to modify themselves than you'd
expect you'd also mentioned that the
speed at which they experience things
has some kind of unchangeable limit to
it so if they start processing
information really really fast then they
actually get some form of anxiety where
they don't like this experience and so
these are kind of psychological limits
on the development of AI that I found
really interesting where did these kinds
of ideas come from
a great question I think
you had to find a solution that uh kind
of mitigated the risk of
um that's run away uh computation
explosion which would now create
something that's vastly different than a
digital person
and somehow this is kind of nascent
belief I think in our world that these
digital persons need to be sentient and
so there's something like what's like to
be a digital person
um and just the way it might be very
painful for us to really just have to be
cognitively thinking deeply on some
problem after a while we want to take a
break yeah or if you know we take some
sort of
uh hallucinogenic or so some some
mind-altering substance that really
accelerates things and we now get a
panic attack or we get anxiety because
maybe our senses are extremely
heightened the analogy was just brought
over into the psychology of a digital
person where we say okay now we're just
going to accelerate your compute or
you're gonna have to just compute more
then to me if digital persons aren't
analogous to people they'd also have and
gravitate gravitate towards the comfort
zone where the amount that they have to
learn every day can become uncomfortable
if it's too much yeah it's interesting
to think about their range of
experiences they could have too like the
idea of kind of a data consuming digital
person or maybe there's like a slacker
digital person who only does like a
million computations a second or
whatever it is because they like to
relax and listen to Jazz at 10x speed
between every thought
are there any examples of like
psychologically Rich portrayals of AI
systems and fiction that inspired you to
kind of think about these inner lives
this way
I'm not a very
um this is a Dexter Finley question okay
he's the science fiction uh Guru and
he's the one who's recommended to us
books like those by e m Banks which I've
started reading and have enjoyed yeah
and and quite a number of others um
really would would go to him I think
where I would say
um is that the portrayal is really in
science fiction are those of digital
people as people so the minds that you
have in the culture series uh are have
their personalities they make mistakes
they they have Espionage they Rebel
um and yet these are you know the the
minds that are just way above everyone
else
um
and and yeah this comes back to this
element of uh what does it look like to
be a digital person Tracy do you have
any touch points like in in books or
movies or other media that have affected
the way you thought about AI
and Adeline Moore with also what uh
Corner said and pink round
primarily
um what I've seen in sci-fi so Star Wars
mainly
has influenced a lot of what I thought
around it so
um I I before I met them I didn't really
think much about it but I mentioned when
I was younger I'd watch like a lot of
the Star Wars Star Trek cartoons and
sort of look at it
this could be something but when uh we
started also some of this the stuff that
in this project then
um I think also Conrad mentioned the
Dexter does a b c d would you be
interested in seeing some of these
things I'm like oh wow so this this is
this is quite interesting yeah
how has thinking about some of these
ideas in this deeper way now changed
your perspective can you point to
anything that's kind of shifted in your
sense of what AIS could be like after
working on this project
when you think of AI you imagine
something abstract that's out there that
will probably not get to where you are
right now but sort of now working on the
projects sort of brings like a flow and
brings it closer
um and more real to my situation right
now and to where we are right now as a
planet sort of making it not an abstract
thing that is just there and for other
people that speak about but also
something that
um I see and I can be a part of and I
can actually find literature that's
about different sorts of tools that are
coming up and different sorts of ideals
and ideas that are coming up around it
as well
that's so cool to hear yeah one of our
hopes with this whole project is kind of
having that impact on all the people who
will now see your world and just making
them really think more concretely about
what some of these abstract seeming
advances might mean for their lives and
their relationships with people and
their experiences in the world
[Music]
the process of World building has great
potential to make a positive future feel
more attainable this can be incredibly
powerful whether you're a creative
person looking to produce Rich works of
fiction or have a more technical focus
and are looking to reach policy makers
or the public
I asked Tracy and Conrad what kind of
impact they hope their work would have
on the world
I'd like to hear a little bit about what
your hopes for the impact of your world
are most broadly
I'd like
to see a world where
um I think this process has already
started
um we can see kind of an epistemological
challenge
with institutions and authorities during
covid where experts you had half a
population all of a sudden discredit
them for political reasons
um I do not want to reject that fully
the world I hope we can create is a
world that what matters most is the most
competing explanation about some sort of
phenomenon and not about who shares that
explanation
this is a world where arguments cannot
be made with one-line tweets but it's
it's uh it's a world where Nuance is
demanded in discourse in everyday lives
it's a place where
everyone knows that there's no such
thing as certainty and so there's always
this openness to be wrong there's always
this openness to accept we are fallible
um and yet we also still believe that
one can be getting closer to the truth
yeah it's so cool to hear you know
hearkening back to what Tracy was saying
with how Chachi bt-like systems are
forcing people to think more about where
their information comes from and its
quality like these Technologies are
already kind of pushing us towards
thinking more about epistemology and how
how knowledge is created and and
validated and what knowledge even is so
there's already kind of that link
happening in our world
and Tracy what do you hope people come
away from this world thinking about I'm
thinking more of
if paying more attention to your
intention and for it to be
an intention that comes from
a place of goodness and not malice where
I'm doing something not just for my good
but for all of us as a whole so if if we
are working together we're working
towards a common I'd say a common good
of
um a holistic and more welcoming sort of
society as Conrad mentioned of course
where discourse is allowed
um you're allowed to have your own
opinion but still that doesn't hinder us
from working together
um not a scenario where I am fighting
you for the sake of me having my way but
agreeing on a common goal where we can
all live and agree together in harmony
yeah
so earlier you were mentioning some
media that kind of shaped the way you
were thinking about Technologies in the
future is mostly kind of like Western
media like Star Trek Star Wars kind of
stuff do you have any thoughts about
like what it would do for us to have
more perspectives from other parts of
the world joining the conversation about
the future in a bigger way
yeah
um there's this power in seeing
something expressed by someone who looks
like you so in this way that if you see
more characters explaining certain
thoughts like let's say if I saw more
women explaining or more women of color
um African women explain some of these
thoughts to me you know it would it
wouldn't seem very abstract it wouldn't
seem up in the sky it would seem
something that's closer to me something
that
um would happen in my lifetime or in my
future but would happen also in Africa
in the Kenyan setting so there is power
in seeing media
and listening to media that sounds
familiar and uh that's that's been my
belief through a lot of the work I'm
doing and also still continuing with it
so even for my past younger self it
wouldn't seem like a very foreign thing
if I saw more
expressions of this of people who look
like me yeah well thank you both so much
for for all of your time and for putting
all of your thought and love that you
put into this world to share with us I
really appreciate this conversation
thank you for engaging with us and
letting us share our thoughts yeah
definitely really appreciate it
um yeah thank you for having us I've had
fun yeah this is a lot of fun
foreign
[Music]
Whitaker you can learn more about
Tracy's company funky science at
funkyscience.co.ke that's fun ke
science.co.ke you can see some of
Conrad's writings at Conrad
whitaker.substack.com and their third
teammate Dexter Finley has a Trilogy of
science fiction novels called the
unmarked series which is available on
Amazon he also has a portfolio page at
dexterstacy.netlify.app
[Music]
podcast has got you thinking about the
future you can find out more about this
world and explore the ideas contained in
the other worlds at www.worldbuild.ai
we want to hear your thoughts are these
worlds you'd want to live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast to read
all the comments and appreciate every
rating this podcast is produced and
edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute
as a non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
in touch with us or any of the teams
featured on the podcast to collaborate
you can email World build at
futureoflife.org
a reminder this podcast explores the
ideas created as part of fli's World
building contest and our hope is that
this series Sparks discussion about the
kinds of Futures we all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
[Music]